what's going on guys this is rob and we
are back with another installment of
beyond omega level where we break down
the most powerful characters and comics
and in today we have a classic marvel
villain that has been requested several
times in the comments dormammu so
dormammu was created by stan lee and
steve ditko and first appeared in
strange tales number 126 of 1964. so
back then strange tales was the book
where dr strange stories were told and
each issue basically told a different
story in a villain of the month type
format without much continuity from one
issue to the next but one thing that did
show up in multiple issues was the name
dormammu as he would be mentioned as the
source of power for various spells now
eventually as stan lee explained readers
became curious to know who he was so he
knew that he needed to create an actual
character to go along with the name and
so adorama is a member of a race of
extra dimensional magical beings made of
pure energy known as the fall team now
dormammu is a mutant of a species
however as he's not a perfect copy of
the original member of his species
instead of desiring energy like the rest
of the falten dormammu craves matter and
so after murdering the progenitor of the
foul teen somebody named sinifer
dormammu and his sister umar find the
dark dimension and win the trust of its
king so that he ends up making them
advisors to the throne now when the king
of the dark dimension dies dormammu and
umar rule it together until dormammu
turns on his sister and banishes her to
a pocket dimension to claim the throne
for himself now when we first see
dormammu he's basically trying to
conquer earth which is what you do when
you're a villain in the 60s which of
course draws him into battle with doctor
strange and dormammu actually gains an
advantage in the contest before the two
of them are forced to work together to
stop the mindless ones from invading
dormammu's dark dimension now after
strange and dormammu repel the invasion
dormammu promises not to invade earth
again but as time goes on his bitterness
and embarrassment over the fact that he
needed strange's help causes him to
become strange's archrival and most
fearsome villain now dormammu is made up
of pure magical energy and his powers
come from his ability to manipulate that
energy which he does in a variety of
ways including energy projection
teleportation and matter manipulation
now doctor strange has described
dormammu as being not only his greatest
enemy but a threat to the existence of
the universe and dormammu is one of the
most powerful mystical beings in the
entire marvel universe save for probably
zom and his energy attacks were potent
enough to begin disintegrating the
cosmic abstract eternity which is one of
the most powerful beings in all of mama
comics as he's the embodiment of all
reality and so dormammu was literally
threatening to destroy all of reality
itself when he battled eternity and the
fight ends up nearly killing both of
them suggesting that dormammu's power
level is comparable to marvel's
abstracts now eternity is not the only
insanely powerful being that dormammu
has displayed his awesome power against
dormammu was able to blind shumogorath
and cause him to retreat and for those
who aren't clear on how powerful
shumogorath is i've done a beyond omega
level video on him before but suffice it
to say he's beyond omega level in his
own right and loki after becoming
sorcerer supreme was terrified of
dormammu and on the occasion loki
briefly gained dormammu's power it drove
him insane now on another occasion
dormammu was able to defeat not only
loki with the greatest of ease but
squirrel girl as well as i'm sure you
all know squirrel girl has defeated
doctor doom thanos and galactus so we're
dealing with some real heavy hitters
here
the fact that dormammu has been
consistently able to match up with
doctor strange is impressive enough by
itself at one point doctor strange was
written to be one of the strongest
characters in marvel comics like he was
absurdly powerful to the point where
eventually the writers had to power him
down by a substantial margin just so
they could start telling compelling
stories but throughout their long
rivalry dormammu has managed to gain the
upper hand on doctor strange and even
remarked that he would be able to erase
him from existence if he wanted dormammu
has also managed to defeat multiple
other sorcerer supremes during his
lifetime as well and even the ancient
one at the height of his power could not
defeat him according to mephisto one of
the rulers of the various hell
dimensions dormammu is capable of
destroying asgard as well as mephisto
and all the other hell lords if he
decided to which is nuts he was also
able to bind zom an extremely powerful
extra-dimensional entity and it said
that dormammu would be capable of
destroying not only earth but the entire
universe as well as time itself now in
addition to that dormammu is incredibly
durable and has taken some incredibly
powerful magical attacks including a hit
from thor's hammer mjolnir and an attack
from doctor strange containing all the
magic in the universe he's also proven
to be one of marvel's most powerful
magical entities and that he's pulled
off some ridiculously impressive magical
feats including the construction of
dimensional barriers taking away thor's
divine power and turning the hulk into
pure crystal he's also proven to be more
powerful than the eye of agamotto one of
the most powerful magical artifacts in
the universe and was able to control the
scarlet witch which would be impressive
at full strength but dormammu did it
while he was in a weakened state and
these are only just a few of the many
magical feats that dormammus pulled off
but i think they all give you a good
sense of just how vastly powerful this
guy is now dormammu is also able to lend
his powers to others as well and they've
been able to do some ridiculous things
when tapping into his vast power source
for example while dormammu was
empowering the demon satanish his fight
with mephisto nearly ripped the universe
in half and he was able to tear holes in
the fabric of reality and when doctor
strange was shown what he could do with
the power of dormammu he saw that he was
able to destroy the ancient one and
several other powerful mystical figures
so yeah dormammu is quite powerful and
probably too often overlooked when
discussing marvel's most powerful
characters because he usually ends up
ultimately losing to doctor strange in
some of their battles because he's the
bad guy and the good guys win otherwise
you'd end up with old man logan but it's
impossible to deny that when you look at
what dormammu is capable of this guy is
stupidly op but with that being said
guys we're gonna bring this to an end
which by the way we need to cover the
story where dora mamu fought schumacher
honestly until i was making this video i
had no idea that happened we need to
cover that man anyway guys we're going
to bring this to an end thank you guys
for watching and i will catch you all
later
peace